c'est ça comment cheval je pense que tu
faisais de l'équitation non je suis du
cheval un agrès attend you say cyrus est
bien un seul épisode du coup de fil je
suis vraiment désolé c'est une autre
discussion très ça ressemble vachement
une discussion plus on était vraiment
une
est-ce que j'ai racheté pas dans mon
monde et lui étaient dans le sien est ce
que nos réalités sont vraiment croisés
est ce que mon esprit a vraiment un
impact sur le monde extérieur
est-ce que genre là j'ai la sensation de
lever ma main mais c'est vraiment moi
qu'il fait adresser les questions que se
posait un certain philosophe
aujourd'hui on va parler de la monade de
leibniz l'une des questions les plus
récurrentes en philosophie c'est celle
de la métaphysique
petit rappel la métaphysique c'est la
connaissance des réalités immatériel qui
sont au-delà des réalités physiques
matérielles genre par exemple savent
être dieu l'amour où les idées ça peut
être aussi du coup la recherche de
l'essence de la nature de l'être des
choses par exemple une question qu'on se
pose beaucoup en métaphysique
c'est de pouvoir qualifier la substance
la substance c'est la réalité permanente
qui sert de support au phénomène qui eux
sont les attributs changeant genre si je
prend de l'eau à l'état liquide l'état
gazeux
ça change pourtant ça reste de l'eau à
cause de quelque chose ce quelque chose
c'est la substance
pareil pour toi tu as changé énormément
sur les dix dernières années mais si on
pense au toit d'il ya dix ans ben est
quelque chose qui est resté pareil c'est
toi en fait c'est toujours toi et c'est
à cause de la substance et il ya eu
plein théorie différentes pour essayer
d'expliquer mais l'une des plus connues
celle de descartes lui la firme qui a
deux substances différentes
il ya l'étendue et la pensée reste
extensa rsq aux beatles mais tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord et les neet il
va encore dans un autre délire gottfried
willem leibniz est un philosophe
allemand du xviie siècle philosophe
ce serait vraiment vraiment réducteur de
dire ça il s'intéresse à l'histoire au
droit à la biologie la physique aux
mathématiques il donne son nom à une
formule la formule de lagnes it et
permet aussi de vachement développer le
calcul infinitésimal
il crée des inventions aussi genre une
machine qui permet d'assécher des mines
ou un système d'ouverture de bouteilles
ou une montre de poche qui seront
montrées elle même bref il était aussi
conseiller à la cour le mec est une
brouille qui est une droite ici reposera
gottfried wilhelm leibniz créateur de la
formule de leibniz fabricant d'une
machine à dessécher les mines
inventeur du chiffre 3 guérisseur de la
lettre inventeur du filtre nashville sur
une star grâce
mais pour lui une substance ça peut pas
être une étendue comme 10 des cartes
parce qu'une détendu ça se divise alors
que ce qui n'est pas véritablement un
maître n'est pas non plus véritablement
un être pourquoi parce qu'au fond la
substance c'est ce qui s'oppose au nom m
et seul peut résister aux noms être ce
qui est un décomposable genre si tu as
encore exclu le décompose dans un bras
une jambe et ceara mais c'est plus
encore c'est pour ça qu'ils cherchent
l'unité donc ça peut pas être l'étendue
divisible ça va être indivisible et
cette chose pour la limite c'est
l'énergie et cette énergie
il l'a appelé atom atom ça vient
d'atomes au sens grec ça veut dire
insécables indivisible mais c'est pas là
tout couvrir tous parce que celui qu'on
connaît tous il envoie recomposait de
truc c'est la matière physique
non lui cherche la vraie unité il va
appeler ça la monade c'est un atom
métaphysique
c'est une substance simple sans parti
c'est une substance individuel c'est
l'unité d'énergie innatendue indivisible
la miss dira que ce sont les véritables
atome de la nature inventeur de la purée
ingénieurs de la ps4 membres des daft
punk deux fois président du panama
hauteur de la bible professeur de gabes
perquié de donald trump
alors là comme ça forcément si c'est pas
physique mais métaphysique c'est un peu
abstrait du congrès c'est quand même de
mieux cerner la monade déjà si ça n'a
pas détendu et que c'est pas divisible
bassin points ensuite vu que c'est une
substance simple et pas une substance
composée va pas y avoir de formation ou
de dissolution puisqu'il va pas y avoir
des partis qui vont s'ajouter ou se
séparer un tout va apparaître d'un coup
ou disparaître d'un coup création et
animation et enfin leibniz nous dit
qu'elle n'a pas de fenêtre
ça veut dire que rien n'est pas agir sur
l du dehors tout se passe à l'intérieur
d'elle-même
alors là ça devient un peu compliqué à
concevoir non peut trouver une analogie
c'est celle de la confiance une
confiance pas un cerveau juste une
conscience alors pareil c'est innatendue
ensuite c'est indivisible sauf quand est
ce qu'ils au non non ça c'est une
maladie de la conscience c'est pas la
conscience en tant que tel et de la même
façon chaque conscience et sans fenêtre
sert qu'on ne peut agir sur la
conscience du dehors
tout se passe dedans quand tu perçois du
rouge ça se passe dans ta conscience
si on ouvre ton air optique on va pas
trouver de rouge les phénomènes de la
conscience viennent du dedans genre là
je vous parle
ça fait des ondes sonores sa part vient
à votre appareil auditif et c'est vous
qui l'interprétait ça vient du dedans
tout se passe en aile à l'intérieur
comme lemonade les brade 2010 les
roulades les mêmes dates les blattes la
cngs les modèles de l'élite
la meilleure technique du lourd oui
parce que les monades aussi perçoivent
elles ont une perception du monde qui
les entoure et d'ailleurs ça va être un
élément très important pour les
distinguer parce que pour l'instant avec
votre description en fait toutes les
monades se ressemblent alors qu'au final
c'est pas le cas on peut les distinguer
on doit les distinguer mais c'est le
principe des indiscernable de la glisse
il n'ya jamais dans la nature deux êtres
qu'ils soient parfaitement l'un comme
l'autre
alors comment les distinguer avec la
perception en fait c'est plutôt simple
chaque mot nahd est situé dans l'espace
1 c'est pas un point de l'univers c'est
un point de vue sur l'univers serre que
suivant le lieu où elle et elle va voir
l'univers avec un angle différent
sa situation fait partie de son essence
sert qu'elle se définit aussi par sa
situation et cette perception c'est même
ce qui permet de mettre en place un
système de hiérarchie entre les monades
en fait c'est simple non vraiment
la limite c'est un homme de continuité
en maths et l'arrachement travailler la
notion d'infini
pour lui tout est continuité la nature
et continuité ça peut pas être autrement
et c'est pareil avec nos perceptions tu
as une perception inégale des choses un
pour la limite tu as les grandes
perception est allé petit perception
qu'ils sont plus confuses et qui permet
d'assurer une certaine continuité par
exemple pour lui quand tu dors tu as
plein de petites perception et tu te
rends pas compte et c'est ça qui permet
d'assurer la continuité entre ce que tu
es en allant se coucher
est ce que tu es le matin en se
réveillant ou bien alors quand tu
marches vers la mer
n'attendons pas le bruit des vagues puis
tu les entends c'est parce que pour lui
en fait les petites perception donc les
gouttes etc se sont additionnés jusqu'à
franchir le seuil d'une grande
perception donc tu l'as entendu tout et
continue si cette différence de degré de
perception qui va permettre de
hiérarchiser les monades ya d'abord le
plus bas niveau c'est celui de la monade
simple c'est celle qui va n'avoir que
des petits perception c'est par exemple
le niveau végétales ensuite il ya des
monades capable de perception plus clair
et de mémoire c'est la monade animal que
la glisse pas appelé âme et un troisième
niveau c'est celui où les monades vont
avoir une conscience réfléchi de leur
perception c'est l'esprit c'est le cas
des mots nature humaine
non non non à la hiérarchisation eu même
animal végétal
le won a tenté égal mais cette
perception de la monade elle n'est pas
passive la monade s efforce d'avoir une
perception plus clair et plus distincte
de l'univers
je vous rappelle que c'est une énergie
et cette impulsion intérieur et ben ça
s'appelle la pétition et ça ce signe pas
donc vous pouvez retenir que la monade
c'est une substance qui est simple il
est tendu indivisible active sans
fenêtre et qui est voué da pétition et
de perception mais il ya malgré tout une
question qui se pose une question
basique
bon maintenant je peux vous le dire je
suis une monade pas mon corps mois film
honnête encore c'est une substance
composée donc c'est un hamman monade qui
est dominé par une monade centrale mois
mais ce qui est difficile à comprendre
c'est comment mon corps et moi on marche
si bien ensemble
alors que les monades c'est sans fenêtre
et donc il n'y a pas d'interaction entre
elles pour essayer de résoudre ce
problème lines a imaginé deux horloges
qui indique exactement très précisément
tout le temps la même heure et pour lui
ça peut s'expliquer de trois manières ou
bien les deux horloges s'influencent
mutuellement
il est un système qui passe d'une
horloge à l'autre pour régler un petit
décalage qui pourrait se faire ou bien
les deux horloges ont été réglés
extrêmement minutieusement dès le départ
leibniz penche pour la troisième
hypothèse en sous-entendant que c'est
dieu qui a fait ce réglage
un petit peu comme un chef d'orchestre
qui donnent des indications à ses
musiciens en fait l'indépendance des
monades est garantie par leur dépendance
à dieu c'est la scène du début
si deux hommes croient communiqué c'est
parce que dieu trouvant chaque monade
les raisons qui l'obligent à s'adapter à
l'autre
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'harmonie
préétabli préétabli donc par dieu
la monade demonhades c'était ravis
d'apprendre que tu es une monade ça me
fait plaisir n'est-ce pas passé le coup
de fil un ami et à ta bonne et c'est pas
déjà fait on se voit très prochainement
pour une prochaine vidéo d'envoi du love
et de la peace cup n'est ce pas cette
vidéo vous aura plu elle est vachement
plus complexe que beaucoup d'autres
façons dès qu'on touche au close up
allemand ça peut compliquer il ya pas
mal de choses dont j'ai pas parlé par
rapport à la liste parce que c'était
déjà très dense par an je vais me du
coût des pistes dans la description avec
un agrément des différents conseils
c'est des mots clés qui pourraient vous
intéresser si la monade vous a plu le
prochain poutine soir un truc un peu
plus simple vous avez vu j'aime bien
alterner les costumes simples et les
coups très compliqué donc sur le
prochain coup de fil c'est un peu plus
de temps en tout cas merci pour vos
retours soient dernière vidéo ça fait
vachement plaisir
ça fait plaisir n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur facebook twitter et son chat
et un énorme merci pour les si peur que
tu de soutenir le projet ces enfants
plus jeunes merci beaucoup
ciao